Okay so let's tease out some of the details here. What
I'd like to do is assemble a complete record for carrier
and airport for all of the data maintained in this database.
Okay. So what' I'm talking about here is doing the necessary queries
against this site. In this case I would need to do
two queries for each carrier and airport pair. And end up with
a table of data that looks something like this. Now I
may decide to store it as a table or JSON. The format
doesn't matter here. So much is the data wrangling
from the site. Okay. So, for every carrier and airport
in a given month, I want to know both
how many departures and arrivals there were for that airline.